[Music]
um I think everyone here that's trying
to get to the next level uh you you need
this and then Ivan I think you need this
too okay so
remember at the
beginning I think it's
fine even if it's
external to learn how to push on
someone's Center like where is that spot
on their body as opposed to like you're
pushing around or you're like oh That's
too great and I'm I can't push it at
all and as you all in the patreon group
have tackled the cook you said I think
that is uh where a lot of you are and
that's fine for where your ey okay um I
say keep working it so Rio for example
you you did a lot of improvement since
the first video uh in terms of where's
your balance to be able to push that so
if you task yourself with just being
able to push that you're going to start
correcting a lot of the other things
like the structural Integrity of the qua
uh where's midfoot right where's your
line of gravity and all that is
necessary okay
um but once you get to a certain level
you have to realize a negative
consequence of that uh just pushing on
the center and that is that you're
really using skeletal alignment and the
problem with that is skeletal alignment
can only go in the 180 degree uh
opposite Vector to the push okay so if
you pay attention
as we're here you can only push back on
the line that he's actually pushing you
on okay um and so what that what usually
happens is you're just in their
shoulders you just push in their
shoulders like that that's what happens
okay and we don't want to push in the
shoulders uh because it doesn't generate
the center
seizure and ultimately it won't be as
reliable in generating kazushi and then
it won't generate the Dilemma the
Marshal dilemma where they either don't
free their Center then you're going to
throw them or they now have to stop
their attack lose initiative in order to
free their Center okay that's the
Dilemma you want so when you're just in
the shoulders uh you won't get any of
that okay and uh what it is if I think
about it is actually let me have my
people try that and so here's the first
discovery learning is whatever drill you
want to don't care if it's external or
not but kind of pay attention maybe you
even need this person to say where they
where they feel it okay uh I'm sure if
you w if you slow this film down and I
might slow it down for you you'll start
to see that his his shoulders are moving
before anything else right maybe he can
feel the weight coming off his left foot
do you see and it's starting to move
those shoulders back is what's happening
okay so you might need your UK to tell
you where they feel it but I think that
you can feel it too that the the energy
is just going straight out from the
angle that my arms are going okay so
let's we're going to try that
okay
so now
the rebounding force that we're sending
out um again what is it where how does
it
actually uh manifest how does it act
what are its properties okay and um
let's ask the question can can it be
curved through space or does it always
have to go on a straight line and I'm
going to say it always has to go on a
straight line okay if it'll it'll follow
the path that it's on until it acts on
something else okay so it's not that I'm
going to take my my
electromagnetism right all that and and
and and take control of his fascia and
and confuse his mind and you know now
the for the rebounding energy is curving
through space and so that it curves
through his body and then that's how you
hit the center and not the shoulders
that ass okay that's just not
true
okay so I'm going to give you a gross
example first so here here he is pushing
okay and what I'm going to do is instead
of just pushing and keeping the
relationship between our hands I'm just
going to change change that change that
relationship physically so you can see
it okay and he'll feel that came out of
my shoulders and came where would you
say it is
now somewhere a little lower okay so I
was here like that and I'm going to
physically and he'll feel the
force that I came lower where it was
pushing okay it wasn't that I took this
line you could you could do that you
could do that but it's kind of still
going up if you pay attention do you see
still going up maybe not as high on it
gross at this point here I'm here like
that
and I push through there okay all right
we'll try that Discovery you all come
close enough so you can I want you to be
able to describe what's happening okay
so we're going to watch Virginia's
technique it's right on the money she's
going to do this
drill okay so she's going to get in his
shoulders first there she is she'll do
the gross
movement it starts to
lower and then she's pushing do the same
thing again we're watching where her
Force line
is good and we'll do it one more time
and that will bring our attention to
Taylor's
Body okay
okay e
you see that reaction in his midsection
as it got a little lower all right we'll
have you two come out Sean you're the
Naga and we're going to watch this
again and we'll watch it one more time
right and then we'll watch it again and
we'll watch for Maya's
body
okay e
what did you
see you can talk
too the shoulders it's still it's still
higher it's still in the shoulders okay
what else did you see
you can talk or you her seem her seemed
to kind of go
over which would be shoulders Maya yes
UK it felt like it went more over rather
than collapse through the center what's
going over uh
the the vector that's pushing her I'm
not sure I understand can you take the
camera and then you show us what you
mean my come out
what what cuz she's she's not the
N so her push is doing what no that when
Sean was go even though he was low she
would still look like she would go up
and yes that that was Andre's point he
still in the shoulders okay um Can
anyone notice what was different between
their two cuz it's not magic the force
line is going into the shoulders
the force Line's not going into the
shoulders Sean has Force line still on
the shoulders or at least higher than
Virginia's Virginia is lower not in the
shoulders okay and and the line goes
straight the force line goes straight so
what is it what's
different Sean picks his foot up and
it's more of a step and I don't think it
has anything to do with the foot does it
it has has to do where it whether it's
external internal it has nothing to do
where is the force Vector is the
question you you could do whatever the
freak you want with everything is where
is the force Vector is it up here or is
it down here so sh has an upwards angle
going that way J has a more flat
trajectory going straight across well we
know it we know that it went higher I
wouldn't say it was exactly in her
shoulders it's a little lower okay that
that's like the third or fourth time
that I said that it is higher than
Virginia's it's not in the midsection
but it's not exactly in the shoulders
okay um but we did see it eventually get
to her shoulders okay where you saw her
shoulders move
okay so I know the reaction already so
now it's what did they do different do
you get it not not more what what how
did UK we already got that what what
they had to do something and we already
know that their Force line is at
different heights okay so what happen
and don't tell me Sean's taller than
Virginia okay it doesn't matter the
height they're they're
vectoring at different places on the
body
how that's the
question okay we're going to watch it
again so we'll just use the same food
game we're going to watch him again
watching
here and then we're going to watch
her okay what was different
well you see this is this is where you
you're only going to get as good as
you're observing okay if you don't if
you can't observe your deviations you're
going to just be deviating all the time
okay so I would tell
you obviously I don't think this is a
slide on Sean he is where he is she is
where she is but you know this one gets
really close to me on my skill on my
skill right I told you that not very
long ago on that last thing that one
evening okay and we know that oh you
keep doing a lot of tension and things
like that okay
so but we're not exactly aware of what
we're doing okay so if you pay
attention when you push in the
shoulders you take this this grip here
and you push on the
grip you see that and what she did was
she's not
pushing with the part that's being
touched okay so kind of leave this on
here cuz that's where I feel your most
pressure those fingers take the rest
open
okay this is what Shan is pushing
on that part
when he comes
down he does the same
thing where does it go when Virginia
changes the
vector she's not pushing on that part
she's
pushing with this on that she's
here you see she's pushing like that
you guys see that okay so don't change
anything and see if you could spot that
okay so from out you could be that again
Virginia push it push it in the
shoulders go just push into the
shoulders first drill push into the
shoulders go good then he lowered it
he's still pushing on those fingers when
he lowers it lower it no lower the drill
hello and he's still going to push there
she's going to go
and she's pushing with this here do do
you feel that now so if you open your
hand she's still going to project
you come
back you
grab open your hand
do you see okay
so what Virginia did is change which
part of her
arm is pushing which part of your grip
do does everyone understand that's what
happened in that
exercise unless you do the same
thing you see that but when you come
when I come here where where do you feel
the weight do you see it's in your palm
and stuff and now I'm in your Center
okay got got it okay that but that's a
gross movement so when I'm here at
shoulder height what I'm going to do is
find the contact point of her grip and
my arm where it doesn't go straight into
the shoulder but I'll use the part that
is starting to get it going do you feel
that okay so it's not it doesn't have to
be a gross movement because gross
movement might not even do anything okay
so where where I'm at I find where I'm
at to get I start to change that
pressure do you see that is where I am
so now my arms aren't dropping but she
feels the weight going going down and
boom I'm I'm in the center without
having to do the gross move me do you
understand
that
e e
again because it's just a physical
property it's not going to be something
different when you do the gross
movement I'm just now sensitive enough
which is which contact
[Music]
point on in your hand and which contact
point on my arm am I putting her young
aspect do do you get it and that's what
changes it when you end up in the
shoulders you're just pushing all the
time on the fingers okay if you wanted
to do that you could do that but if you
don't want to do that
you get more wherever you want do you
understand okay all right so we're here
and here's Discovery learning you're
here I want you to go into the shoulder
shoulders okay I want you to feel where
it is and maybe get really gross
movements so she's really driving on me
okay as long as you if if it if you
can't do that it's not going to be
successful okay so but get it as high as
you can and now start changing where
you're sending that rebounding
energy uh on on her okay and you keep
trying to lower what part is it coming
back through what what part and you
should be able to feel it you can make
it go back
up you can start making it go back
down
okay all that happens in micros seconds
but it's really no different from the
standing meditation where you
feel the gravity the force right the
chap dropping it's the same exact thing
okay but it's very requires harder
degrees of Sensi ity but you're never
going to get there if you just
absentmindedly without awareness push on
where you feel the initial contact Point
okay where you felt that pressure okay
all right try